hello everyone and welcome back to round
two of the tata steel chess tournament
in a really really uh exhausting game
between david anton guihara and
magnus carlsen this is uh david anton's
first game against
world champion magnus carlson in
classical time format so of course he
wants to do very well
and this one was uh well it was really
wild it took over six hours and
uh well let's just see what what
happened here this game is not for
everyone so you know just a fair warning
so uh anton
opens with uh e4 and the magnus of
course when he faces e4 he
more often than not goes for his
sicilian which is something he prepared
uh
ver very well i see he played it in
every game against fabiano carwana
in their 2018 world church championship
match so it's uh
fair to assume for david anton that
magnus will go for this knight to f3 we
have knight to c6
and now and not going for the open
sicilian right away
but first knight the c3 and now uh he
wants to see whether magnus will go g6
e5 e6 or
or what not magnus goes for g6 he wants
the fiance to his dark square bishop and
now
david anton strikes in the center we
have d4
capture sunday for knight captures and
now with bishop to g7 we've transposed
into the
the accelerated dragon variation of the
of the sicilian defense
uh which is incredibly sharp and the
white has uh
several ways of how he can go for it uh
david anton goes for bishop to e3
and usually you want to go also f3
g4 h4 and just bust open
black's king side so here knight to f6
by magnus
and now uh again a lot of possibilities
here bishop the c4 is an option a bit
more timid bishop to e2
f3 is an option preparing g for g for an
h4
but here we have knight to b3 which is
somewhat rarer
uh we have d6 and now f3
and here magnus went into a pretty deep
thing
almost 20 minutes maybe some 18 and a
half and he played bishop to e6 and
the last time this position was on the
board it was in 2006 so it's very
unlikely
that david anton has this prepared but
who knows as he also
needs to uh well do something about this
so it looks kind of weird blocking your
own e-pawn but
magnus of course knows what he's doing
so queen to d2
uh david anton prepares the castle queen
side and now
d5 by magnus and there is only one game
in the database that
reached this exact same position and
here magnus is asking
david anton whether he wants to just
trade down into an end game or does he
want to keep the pressure
uh because there is kind of some
pressure on david anton as he does have
the white pieces so he might want to go
for a win here
uh but you know that's easier said than
done when you're playing
in classical against magnus so here
basically if you trade off everything
for example he captures knight captures
knight captures queen captures
just everything comes off the board
captures captures let's say c3
uh it's a pretty equalish endgame but
white really achieved absolutely nothing
so it's kind of like uh throwing away
the the white pieces
and uh that just because you have an
equal position uh against magnus carlsen
on movie 11
doesn't really mean all that much so
here instead after this d5 move
he goes for bishop to b5 and this is a
new move in the position it was never
played before
so already as of move 10 we have a
completely new game
so uh magnus of course doesn't want to
allow uh
this bishop to capture the knight so
maybe he would have to ruin his pawn
structure
so first he goes d captures an e4 uh we
have queen captures and e8
magnus offers a queen trade david anton
accepts rook capture 78
and now f captures on e4 and now magnus
just goes bishop to d7
he could also just castle but like i
said uh he doesn't want to allow
captures and captures and then
of course you also lose the a7 pawn so
you have to do something about that
so after e f captures on e4 we have
bishop to d7 by magnus for the moment
going back
kind of blocking your own rook but again
it's all with uh with a good idea and
here if you go for this this doesn't
really work because then
black will have an attack on the e4 pawn
bishop captures and now if you capture
on
a7 then you lose the e4 pawn so it's a
bit of a trade-off but black
black will be black will be much better
here as the white kick is still in the
center of the board
and you have to be very careful so here
after bishop to d7
uh david anton castles uh and now magnus
goes for the bishop here
knight the g4 also opens up this uh long
diagonal for
for his dragon uh we have bishop to c5
now getting the bishop out of harm's way
and now magnus does something that kind
of seems anti-positional but
it uh it it really isn't and the the
word anti-positional kind of lost
meaning
uh since uh the the appearance of the
engines uh
in chess as now even even humans can
play anything so here bishop captures on
c3
and if this game was played let's say in
1978 uh they would say oh this is a this
is a terrible positional mistake why
would you give up your strong
dark square bishop but here it's
actually the strongest
move recommended by the engine as it
ruins the white spawn structure now as
you can see white has four pawn islands
black has only two and magnus will of
course try to
take advantage of this he plays b6 kicks
away david anton's bishop
and now bishop to g1 and both players
are doing relatively well here on the
clock
uh david antony's on some 50 minutes and
magnus some 55 minutes
you could have also gone to a3 which is
also possible keeping the bishop on this
diagonal
but uh david anton prefers the bishop to
g1
so here magnus centralizes his knight
knight c to e5
offers a trade of light square bishops
and we have bishop back to d3 bishop to
a6 was also a possibility
uh just keeping an eye on that uh c8
square not allowing
the rook to to get the c8 uh but uh
like i said uh white prefers to go all
the way back so instead we have bishop
back to d3
and now uh we have bishop to a4 and now
uh what what is carlson's plan here well
he does have some tricks up his sleeve
for example
uh if you play something like knight to
d4 then you can go knight captures on d3
now the pawn cannot capture because the
rook would hang here
so you'd have to capture with the rook
and then just knight e5 and
black gets a lot of activity here you
can go rook to c8 go after this pawn
once the rook moves
and it's uh it's a nice position for
black so instead of
uh after this bishop to a4 we have rook
bishop to d4
now uh pinning carlson's knight here it
cannot move of course the rook is on h8
uh and here uh well magnus could play f6
but it's very tricky because uh
of course white will play h3 kick away
this knight and then black wants the
capture here to ruin black's pawn
structure
but carlson could always trade just
knight captures with czech c
captures and now magnus even has this
trick of rook captures on d4
for example if knight captures then you
go knight f2 you
uh fork the rooks and after let's say
rook d to f1 attacks the knight now you
trade here captures captures
and again you get to this end game where
white has three pawn islands black has
two but it's a bishop against tonight
black will always be a little bit better
as uh the bishop can cover more ground
as we have pawns on
both sides of the board so instead after
bishop to d4 magnus goes for the
immediate
knight captures on d3 with check c
captures on d3
and now uh he eliminates the defender of
the f2 square
so rook captures on d4 c captures on d4
or you could capture with the knight and
allow bishop captures on d1 you're
losing one of the rooks so
david anton prefers to strengthen his
center even though it kind of messes up
the pawn structure but
the center will be stronger so c
captures on d4 and now knight f2 now
magnus goes after the rooks
king the d2 and now knight captures on
h1 rook captures on h1
it's also maybe not always but you
should always you should always try to
capture the rook that's uh
away from the center that way for
example after captures and captures
here it it doesn't really do all that
much because the rook on d1 wasn't
doing all that much but usually you want
to try and get your opponent's
rook away from from where the action is
and here just e6
uh keeping those uh a light square pawns
at bay uh with
knight to c1 now david anton prepares to
bring the knight into the game
and king to e7 of course now magnus
wants to get the rook into the game as
well
knight to e2 and now bishop back to d7
we have a4 and now rook to c8 putting
the rook on this uh
very nice open c file and now knight the
c3
not not going for rook to c1 trying to
trade rooks because it's uh
it's questionable how the how this
energy would end up for
for white because it also loses a pawn
here so we first have to tend to the a4
pawn so after this rook the c8
knights the c3 defending the the pawn
and now
magnus strikes in the center with f5
we have rook to b1 uh and now f captures
an e4 we have d
capture sunny for undoubling the pawns
and now e5 by magnus and now
uh d5 doesn't really do all that much
for white even though it creates a pass
pawn
uh because black can very easily uh very
easily
blockaded that past pawn and your pawns
are now fixed on light squares white has
light square bishop
so maybe not the greatest course of
action so after king to d3
we have e capture sunday for by magnus
king captures and
rook to c5 and here uh it's just a
very nice position for both of them
still three pawn islands for white two
pawn islands for black
and uh uh david anton's king is very
active
here on d4 and clockwise they are both
uh some 10 minutes on the clock
so here knight the d5 check carlson has
to move the king king f7 and
rook to f1 with check king g7
and now knight back to c3 guarding
everything not allowing the rook to
further activate
we have bishop to e6 and now knight to
b5 going after the a7 pawn
so uh now uh the the rook can come into
the game but you also have to
uh uh check what happens with the a7
pawn so here
carlson goes after the g and h pawn
we have king to e5 first grabbing more
space with the king as it comes with an
attack on the bishop
bishop to g8 and now rook to g1 not
allowing carlson to capture any of those
pawns
and here magnus defends his a7 pawn by
advancing it with a5
knights to d6 and now bishop back to b3
going after that a4 pawn so rook to b1
now if pawn captures then uh we can
capture here on b6
and magnus of course goes for that
bishop captures rook captures and
now rook captures on g2 and here magnus
has won a pawn
but it's going to be very hard to prove
that this is enough for a win so here
they are they've reached move 39 and
with this h4 move
magnus reaches move 40 and as the rules
uh the rules say
if you reach move 40 you get additional
40 minutes on the clock for the next 20
moves and then
after that you get additional i think 20
minutes for for the rest of the game
so here h4 and we have rook to h2 going
after the pawn this is black's 40th move
so magnus also gains uh
his extra 40 minutes on the clock and
now the players can relax a bit because
they now have
plenty of time to think about this
position so magnus goes after the a5
pawn
and here we have a trade captures and
captures and the now comes
bishop to d1 and here we have this uh
endgame where i'm sure both magnus and
david anton have
studied such end games uh immensely
uh two pawns uh for carlson one pawn for
uh david anton and
of course this pawn is going this way
and these pawns are going this way so
is it enough being up upon in this end
game to win this so let's see what
happened
rook to a1 pushing back carlson's bishop
we have
rook to h1 just defending it not not
going for capture because you want to
free up the h file for for pushing that
pawn and there are no tricks for the
moment
for trapping that bishop and even if you
could attack it the just bishop here
would also defend the rook so it's not a
problem
knight's the e8 check we have king to h6
and now
knight to f6 uh now you have to be very
careful if rook to a7 comes there could
be
could be dangerous here so here magnus
goes king to g5 right away
and now there is a trick in this
position here you might think uh okay
let's capture this
let's capture this pawn and then after
rook captures we're gonna capture here
we've won a pawn and this is great but
the problem is the black the black king
prevents the white king from going
anywhere
uh near it uh so here rook the e7 with
check just wins the game because you
either go king to d6 and lose this pawn
and this is now a winning rook end game
for for magnus or you try and save the
pawn you go somewhere here for example
but then just
rook to d7 check king here and uh
david anton would lose the rook here and
of course the game
so instead of this after king to g5 we
have rooked the
a7 again going after that pawn and now
magnus just advances it we have
h5 and knight to h7 with check so now
again if king to g4 then you can go
after this pawn you cannot really defend
it so
you can't even push it because the g5
square will be covered twice
so instead uh magnus goes back king to
h6 and now
knight to f8 and now again what do you
play here
uh here magnus played rook to f1 the
problem with king g5 gaining activity is
again this and you cannot defend against
captures
so here magnus goes rook to f1 and now
comes
rook to h7 with check this is in fact
the best movie if you try something like
96 to cover these squares and go for
some sort of a checkmate
then bishop to g4 is just winning for
magnus
because you you can now start pushing
your pawn so white doesn't have a good
move
you can't really allow to trade here and
it's just going to be just going to be
winning for magnus
so instead we have rook to h7 with check
king to g5 and now knight to e6 with
check we have king to h4 and now rook to
g7 going after this pawn and magnus
needs to defend it so
rook to g1 so the pawn is nicely
defended but it can't
it can't really go to g5 for the moment
and here we have knight to d4
also possible was just king to d6
freeing up uh the
the e file for this pawn and then if g5
e5 and so on
both players continue pushing uh however
here we have
knight to d4 and now comes g5
magnus starts advancing his pawn knight
f5 check
king to h3 and now knight the e3
putting pressure on the bishop here
magnus goes bishop to f3
and now king to f5 and again the time on
the clock is now very different it's
four minutes for david anton
and 36 minutes for magnus and now what
do you do here this pawn is under attack
and magnus uh did think a lot in this
position he played king to h4
but it's actually it's actually very
interesting what happens if g4 is played
this is just a
a very crazy line uh king f4 now bishop
back to e2 the bishop is under attack
and
okay for the moment is defended but if
the pawn is pushed in the bishop hangs
so bishop to e2 and now knight to f5
uh and what do you do here you're gonna
play rook to f1 with
check king to e3 and now the bishop
under attack again
bishop back to b5 and now rook to g5 you
go after the pawn here
but now rook f3 check king to d4 and now
bishop to e8 defending the pawn but it's
not going to be enough for black the
problem is
after let's say rook g8 bishop to d7 and
rook h8
uh white can always uh give up uh give
up material to go for uh for a
theoretical draw for example if g3
you can just capture on h5 with check
and after king to g4
now attacking both of them uh just
knight captures on g3
king captures rook h7 and this is a
theoretical draw even even without
the white pawn that this is still a
theoretical draw you can try winning
this in rapid or blitz but in classical
it's not going to happen
so here after king to f5 magnus doesn't
go for this
uh it's hard to say what uh
how far he he calculated this but he
decides to defend it for the moment king
to h4
uh we have king to e5 and now bishop to
g4 and now bishop to g4 is an ugly move
for black to play because uh well it
just blocks your pawns but
again if you go for the active rook the
e1 attacking the knight and then
of course if the knight moves the pawn
problem is after let's say knight f5
check king h3 and king f6
bishop captures on e4 you're going to
play rook captures on g5 and after let's
say h4
you're gonna play knight captures on h4
and again it's the same thing king
captures rook g7
theoretical draw like we said even
without the pawn
so after this king to e5 move we have
bishop to g4 by magnus
ugly but what are you gonna do and now
king to d4
again making room for the pawn to be
pushed and now bishop to h3 by magnus
here was probably probably a worth uh
worth checking out is rook to a1 point
is that you want to
prevent the pawn from reaching e6 and
the rook and bishop could do a fine job
of that for example if e5 rook to a6
stops
the pawn from pretty much ever reaching
e6 and maybe you can
move the bishop and start pushing your
own pawns however we have bishop to h3
by magnus
again it's very hard to to activate that
bishop
and now e5 magnus does go for rook to a1
now
but now comes rook to g6 uh guarding the
square
so now if rook to a6 rook to a6 is now
impossible
uh here we have rook to a4 check and now
a couple of tricks king the d5
rook a5 checking to d4 rook to a4 check
king to d5 rook a5 check and now if
magnus repeats
uh then uh it's going to be a king d4
and now if magnus repeats rook to a4
check it's going to be a draw by
threefold repetition
so magnus still uh hopes to to get a
full point he goes
rook to a8 and he's he's still up upon
so maybe he can do something
we have e6 by black by white now the
pawn is defended here and
rook to e8 magnus now ready to capture
the pawn
but king the e5 just defending it and uh
here bishop to g4 by magnus again uh you
could you could start pushing that pawn
but uh
you'd be very sorry because knight step
5 is checkmate here
so this is something you can easily
overlook when you're playing chess
uh because uh you know it seems like a
great position because you know
everything is
everything is nicely in place but it's
very easy to mess this up
a g4 knight five checkmate so of course
magnus saw this he played bishop to g4
first and now king to d6 uh going closer
and closer after that rook
uh and here there's just no good way of
continuing the game that
passport is already a monster if it
comes to e7 then it's just terrible
so here magnus decided to go for rook
captures on e6
we have rook captures on e6 bishop
king captures on e6 and now king to g3
again g4 is nice but for example after
g4 king to f5
and you go g3 it's not a problem knight
to g2 check and you can just continue
uh with checking knights to e1 and now
again it's a problem g2 knight capture
skin captures and you will
win the pawn as well you're just that
one square too short
for example king here king captures and
it's a draw by insufficient material
so instead after this king captures an
e6 magnus strike king to g3 now just
clearing the h file for his pawn
king to f5 and now magnus went for
king to f3 problem is if you go for h4
just knights to g4 and you can never win
this doesn't matter you can push the
pawn
just king captures and the pawn can
never cross this square because the
knight just captures it
and again a draw by insufficient
material so here after king f5
king the f3 was played going after the
knight but this is now an official draw
for because it's a a trade knight for
two pawns which of course david anton
accepted
and after six gruesome hours six plus uh
the the game ends in a draw and a big
congratulations to david anton
uh for uh getting a draw against the
world champion in his first ever
classical game
uh against magnus so uh yeah really a
wild one there were there was never a
like uh like a forced winning line there
were some better options
maybe but those are you know for a human
to spot i i don't think so
so it was a a pretty wild game magnus uh
offered him an
early draw like we mentioned in that
position where he could have uh just
traded everything
in the center of the board here when
magnus played d5 so
everything could have been traded here
and then you just play this position
against magnus but david anton uh
went for something more he tried it
didn't work out then it was magnus who
was pushing and in the end and draw so
quite
uh quite a you know a struggle so
really really tough game for for both of
them and i'm sure david untone is very
happy with his result
magnus not as much probably but you know
you can't expect
to beat someone with the black pieces in
classical that that would be silly
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game hope
you guys enjoyed it we're going to cover
some more games from route 2 as there
were some very interesting ones
uh i would like to thank joaquim johnson
alexander vaughan uh jerry gauz
uh jan william van gaalin and gc before
a contribution to my channel and also
congratulations
uh and thank you to dimitri luschenko
for becoming a top donor on the channel
thank you a lot sir i really appreciate
it uh
so yeah uh like i said i hope you guys
enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata still checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so uh thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day